in five four three two one hello
everybody today I'm going to say nice
things to you
we're not call you smelly or [ __ ] and
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast how's everybody doing I
think you guys are having a lovely week
if you're taking us with you on your
commute well thank you welcome out of
asses I'm David self I'm Jojen Sakawa
and today we have again a special
special guest Chris soules dignity would
it would it do
yeah so we got this really [ __ ] funny
topic so I checked my Instagram and we
were talking about earlier where a buddy
Vince sent me this clip this dude
dressing up in this colorful poncho it
Boyle Heights of all [ __ ] oasis yeah
and he has a mustache in a sombrero and
I guess he was doing like a Mexican skit
right yeah and he's getting called out
for it and let's watch this video guys
can we can we do it like on yeah on live
just put it on I want to see it okay
so just play it okay so this is the
first part now I'm gonna try to like put
it in the mic so everyone can hear
[Music]
version looking guy in a poncho
oh she said that with such lack of
confidence Oh No all right that was
video one okay here's video two so
basically they're standing there and
he's like what you're an animal like the
guy in the Poncho's like you're an
animal you you can't talk about it and
then yeah the one guy's like well yeah
I'm the animal I'm over here
disrespecting a whole culture or
whatever anyways yeah man this is crazy
so I don't know like maybe you could I
don't know if we could put the video on
or whatever but I'm just gonna explain
if you can't see for the people that are
listening apparently this guy is
Egyptian okay
and he was like nah no it's cool it's
cool magician all right
you're still not Mexican Yeah right yeah
and then his girlfriend's white and then
so like you know obviously Mexicans
didn't like it that he was standing
there in a poncho do I go get the [ __ ]
out of here not of all places man Boyle
Heights you don't [ __ ] around in a hood
man yeah body oh man like I think it's
just weird nowadays cuz like with all
the gentrification and all these people
moving into LA like they just do not
[ __ ] understand how it will go bad
here ya know it is real yeah like dudes
get shot dudes get beat up stabbed
whatever like um you know it's just you
don't want to go there didn't disrespect
a group of people that will throw down
like it's not [ __ ] Santa Monica like
this ain't you know you don't [ __ ]
around right a certain place and I feel
like in that area two things already
kind of sensitive because their area is
getting gentrified right so they're
seeing like all the stuff they loved as
a kid disappear and go away yeah and
they see a bunch of flannel Dan
checkered shirts come in with their
[ __ ] you know expensive coffee and
their mustaches yeah and they see their
their childhood going away and then you
had these guys or this Egyptian man he
thought it was basically look Mexican
bro doesn't really work like that just
because your people made the Sphinx does
not make it okay but just cuz you look
Mexican - it's like hey I'm one of you
guys now
not dude like you know I went down there
rolling with the poncho I think first of
all they'd laugh at me because I'd look
ridiculous
yeah but also just the whole YouTube
[ __ ] right like people doing it for
Klout people doing it to make it ya know
like they get it they think oh you guys
doing a [ __ ] skit here right right
this is a good like basically you're
you're mocking yeah you're mocking us in
our city right in front of us you think
we're just gonna stay here and watch
y'all like be like oh yeah can I be a
part of the sketch like it's just it's
me at least have some Mexicans with you
that's what I'm saying I'm like have
your Mexican homies you know mean which
you'd be like hey not [ __ ] cool doc hey
that's my gypsy homie [ __ ] it yeah
yeah yeah at least or if you're gonna do
that [ __ ] do that [ __ ] at your crib yeah
your message you're saying you got a
good message for whatever what's the
message yeah well I don't know what
messaging positivity dude yeah do it at
your crib man to where you're not you're
in your own you know personal space you
can still wear your poncho like just let
people make those decisions on comments
you know you're safe it's still a piece
of [ __ ] thing see my thing is like a
wearing like like that's like me wearing
a what is it
kimono or yeah and then if I was making
a skit skit about it so am I like
there's the line of like what's gonna be
funny and then what's gonna be racist
you know can likewise like why didn't I
cast somebody who's Asian well because
this is my page and I'm the comedian and
I want to play this role to portray this
yeah you know I mean or behind I
actually have no problems with that like
if you if you made a skit right and like
like we have this one skit where we're
like slanging tee right and we have one
of our black buddies that comes in and
he's like buying tea from us and we're
like acting all hood but we're wearing
like traditional Chinese clothes or like
you know I have cholo characters that I
played a lot of different characters in
a day yeah so like my cholo characters
our Asians that grew up in like Mexico
and stuff and then so so they have that
like like what's not
like that kind of East LA kind of style
yeah and you're right though if you do
it like in a setting that's like you're
not doing it outdoors like [ __ ] with
people Rick I don't know what this is
about but it it looks like they're
outdoors [ __ ] with the community
yeah like pranks and [ __ ] yeah yeah I
don't know how to prank to go to a blood
City a blood street wearing wearing all
blue bandana let's all you know
everything blue a whole blue unit and
thing like I bro so we're on a blood
street right now let's check it out you
know said and they're just like [ __ ]
walking down the whole top side of this
so sorry go me a hundred bucks bro know
what you just gave me a great video idea
I'm doing that tomorrow gotta make it
from one stops on to the other yeah that
would be hilarious and then they get
shot up and [ __ ] yeah do that Mike every
time I saw see like these pranks like I
said I always pray just please one of
them died I just want one of them to die
I just want it to happen once I just
want somebody to get shot just be like a
path [ __ ] told you so yeah cuz then
some people would be scared of it but
nobody has really faced those
consequences you think you're like a
like a neutral reaction to like book he
was like a martyr like he's doing
something great for the society like
yeah [ __ ] like hero like this is for
positivity man like blaming the the the
guys like so you can't blame the guy for
being offended that you're [ __ ] with
his culture you're like why gotta be an
animal and try to fight me for it's like
man what the [ __ ] are you saying right
right like if I went to the south and I
walked around called all these black
people n-word and they get mad at me and
it's like you're being an animal right
now and I went down yeah dude like I
deserve to get my ass beat at that point
like there's always a line right some
people believe like you should never be
violent no matter what I don't [ __ ]
believe that [ __ ] if you provoke someone
enough and you're just being a complete
[ __ ] yeah maybe you should get your
ass beat in there some people do need a
couple hours but yeah
I'm saying just just to straighten up to
be like oh maybe that was [ __ ] up
if you go to a [ __ ] lion right and
you poke that [ __ ] with a stick
all day you deserve to get bit
yeah for sure facts I like this
girlfriend because she was she was not
down she was a fishy way I'm not leaving
without any more than that you dumb
[ __ ] let's let's talk about their
channel so you said it was what Dan and
stupid [ __ ] it was like okay chemo
chemo and Danny David did a good job
finding their [ __ ] Instagram pic I
mean their YouTube page and then they
just do like pranks or whatever it's
like cloud chased more like tried being
homeless in Dubai Indonesia and
villagers try rapping Drake songs
whatever yeah here's the hard part
um I think Tim actually explained this
really well he was he was talking about
the whole situation where a bunch of
youtubers they do a lot of crazy [ __ ]
right yeah and they gain a lot of
attention for it after a while they just
stop being human because they don't know
what's real and what's not
yeah yeah it [ __ ] with them cuz they're
trying to create any type of story any
type of fervor on a daily basis right so
they don't know what those boundaries
are anymore even sometimes to like when
we're out like so Tim does is one thing
now where he just goes before he flaws
he goes hey blog warning and he says
that just to let people know if they
don't want to participate in this they
don't have to mmm but prior to that he
probably didn't do it and but now he
knows like oh not everybody wants to be
in this type of world right so it's a
very odd thing where sometimes when you
have to create content every day these
kids they just don't understand what
you're alive well you gotta let people
know like I'm going live because you we
can just be talking we could be talking
[ __ ] about somebody or you talking [ __ ]
above something that you wouldn't want
people that you're comfortable around
your friends and you got one person on
live and now they hear Joe in the
background nope talking this [ __ ] and
you're like [ __ ] bro like yep you know
that's happened to us we did our circle
of friends man yeah man like a lot of
things is serious bro you know that
should happen just gotta call it out to
like hey I'm vlogging so then people
know oh [ __ ]
right right rabbit would like [ __ ]
when codec was talking [ __ ] about
[ __ ] Oh
man yeah you shouldn't you shouldn't
have like that conversation I can see
that the conversation happening but
behind closed doors behind closed which
your home was you're talking dumb [ __ ]
because obviously it's dump [ __ ] let's
get that out the way that you're saying
some ignorant [ __ ] yeah but the fact
that you got the camera on and it's his
live I would assume yeah I'm saying it
like bro no bro the funny thing was when
he was when he wanted to squash the
whole thing and I think he went on his
Instagram live and he was like yo well
this is what it is he's like you know
how was giving her a cop yes so this is
what his girlfriend said right so she
sent a DM to this dude and then she's
like so she says by the way my family
and I are immigrants and we only came to
the States from Eastern Europe like ten
years ago and are not rich and
privileged as all racist people think so
crazy only the USA has such big degree
of racism the rest of the world doesn't
like this all I want is to end that in
this country as well maybe the approach
suck then we will learn from this but at
least chemo and I are willing to put
ourselves out there and try
most people just talking complaining
about it but never act on it one day
when you feel when you travel and see
the world and experience different
people and cultures you will realize
cultural appropriation is only a problem
in the USA and if we keep approaching it
and racism with hey blah blah blah you
know what's crazy is this [ __ ] has no
[ __ ] idea what the American
experience is all about
obviously cultural appropriation is a
sensitive topic in the u.s. because we
had racism and we had one group that was
very powerful
yeah and they would you know like for
example like you know incarcerate people
for no [ __ ] reason they wanted to or
whatever yeah and she just doesn't
understand race relationships in the in
the u.s. of course it's gonna be since
this country is literally made off of
appropriation we always got wait what
was where we use
the complication cultural appropriation
burgers yeah proprietary yeah yeah yeah
so she's like why why and she's right
too cuz like in Japan they love it when
foreigners come and wear kimonos and and
dress up in the costumes and play all
that [ __ ] because it's tourism and they
don't have the pass hurt right but but
out here in the u.s. if if people are
pretending to be Asian and they [ __ ]
around and do their eyes [ __ ] and then
they wear like ching chong clothes or
whatever the [ __ ] and if they act around
that does it feels different mm-hmm but
if they're out in asia doing it it's not
that weird and so she's kind of she's
I'm in her response is [ __ ] stupid -
because she goes well that's not how it
is at the rest of the world so if you're
so well-traveled right then you should
understand that every time you go to a
country everybody has a different set of
rules and if you're respectful in that
country of their set of rules why can't
you do the same over here then so what
is the change that you're trying to
invoke here right so for example if she
if she traveled - if she went into my
house right and then she didn't want to
take off her shoes because she goes in
my house I didn't I don't give a [ __ ]
pick up your [ __ ] shoes off in my
house I'll slice your feet off about
that [ __ ] but so it doesn't her logic
doesn't make sense if she goes it's kind
of what do you call it
egotistical - yeah she's like once you
[ __ ] travel you'll understand you're
talking like sometimes people can't
afford it yeah yeah like when you're
saying we're not as privileged it's like
obviously you don't understand it some
people just can't afford to travel or
see the world understand outside of
their city like that makes you that is
what privilege is yeah you don't you're
blind to seeing that some people just
can't do that right and if you're trying
to like spread a positive message okay
and you're this is uh let's say you're
trying to do a message for you know
Korea you're not gonna for your for your
video you're not gonna address in a
Korean outfit and then say your message
yeah you can actually still be yourself
or be any other character that's true
and spread your positive message
to be in a poncho a fake as like curly
as mustache occurs at the ends and a
poncho like in our sombrero that's true
to spread your message for what was that
for
yeah what was that is a good question
what the [ __ ] was the message is this
positivity yeah I'll even watch this
[ __ ] man it happened so many with
soma so many [ __ ] youtubers do this
[ __ ] dude about time people get
checked for their [ __ ] yeah it's
kind of weird and how the entitlement
like how people think that it's like man
I'm doing this [ __ ] message for good
see that the internet social media and
everything it allows people to be their
own celebrity yeah so now now it's need
me yeah my fans need me I'm doing this
for the world I'm trying to spread this
and I'm trying to change this and you
actually need to learn your position
yeah and play that role and then you
know once you continue being that role
you progress and then you'll end up
being the person that you want to be but
right now you just stay in your place
yeah and and be in that you know me and
stay in your pocket because you're
stepping over boundaries you're going in
the cities you can get hurt
you don't mean you're going saying I
pray to God somebody gets hurt I'm
praying dude I bet you guys confused
sometimes it's like why do you keep
praying about this dude I'm like your
god you gotta understand man just kill
one of them
I mean we gotta make sacrifices pray
Lord youtubers youtubers die from trying
to prank come on man yeah it's it's bad
you know I mean like it's it and my
thing is this like and this is coming
from a comedian standpoint I don't know
if I'm speaking for all comedians well I
would say but why at what point cuz I'm
trying to play devil's advocate woods
which cheese to charge was a positive
message but I'm talking about common at
what point is something just funny
instead of instead of everybody being
offended which everybody has a right to
be offended yeah but what did but now
you ask okay LGBTQ crew okay
we know that it's it's you know this is
offensive this offense this
okay what is funny to you what is your
line that this will that I can play with
it yeah you know but can I pretend to be
gay right exactly like give me get let
me know and if y'all can't give me a
joke that Laur y'all can't tell me
something that I can't then I should be
able to be free hmm because you don't
even have you don't even know what's
what's offensive or not if you can't
tell me what's gonna be funny yeah and
not everyone agrees to like I think um I
actually don't mind the whole cultural
humor [ __ ] like hilarious like you could
be black and you wear a poncho and it
could be white and pretend to Asian or
whatever I mean cuz I I feel like when
it's for the sake of comedy yeah it
might be bad taste but like it might be
outdated cuz what you know a fifty year
old white dude might like look at
something very different than a twelve
year old white kid right they might find
out this [ __ ] funny right and I know
that there's a lot of outdated racist
jokes out there that old folks still
think is really funny yeah and I'm like
well I mean that's their [ __ ] right it's
it's it's all it's all fun and games in
their world right but when does that
become hurtful and dangerous to society
exactly and then I I think at the end of
the day like when it comes to comedy I'm
okay with a lot of this [ __ ] yeah it's
it's it's it's all good fun it's when
you when you write get out of the studio
when you take it out of the comedy club
and you take it into the real world and
you're [ __ ] with regular citizens
pranking them doing all that [ __ ] yeah
that's what I'm not cool with right
they're not a part of the joke it's not
yeah that's exactly what they're dirty
they they don't they're not miked up
which some prank videos are faking up to
our date they are miked but like people
they're not a part of it they're not
this is not their culture that's not the
world they're not in the internet
they're just walking down the street
you're doing some dumb [ __ ] and you want
us to act like you know like you wanted
to be funny of you but so I agree what
you're saying like outside of the
common-rail outside of the comedy club
or outside of the movies or the TV or
what do these cultural jokes I mean no
you're you can't know you're you can
said a lot of people you can [ __ ] up and
up like but we were talking about this
earlier like if you can nail the accent
and even do the comp if you do the
cultural jokes really well and you do
inside jokes like you'll actually be
appreciated yeah they're like you know
thanks for putting a saw man that was
hilarious yeah is that that that race
card is so hard to I feel like you know
the younger that we are or the group age
really matters cuz now it's just
everybody's trying to be pissed because
it's cool to be pissed yes yeah I mean
it's cool to be angry about everything
it's exactly well when the [ __ ] can we
laugh about [ __ ] then right right
because at this point now it's just it's
a trendy thing to be mad as I know you
can it's more you can't say this now all
the time yeah and some people are
telling me what I can and can't say
about my own culture so I guess my [ __ ]
yeah are they are they your culture
probably not I love that [ __ ] that's my
favorite [ __ ] dude people fight for me
like and then I'm like no I don't need
that you're right bro people just like
to be offended yeah they want to be like
yo this [ __ ] ain't right this is like
they just want to have the power of that
opinion of like I'm offended right now
yes offended me I mean it's it's
something about I don't know what it is
but a lot of people just don't back up
what they're doing either like this they
just want that retweet they want that
like they want to be a part of that
group so far I've had somebody roast me
in a comment and you know and I've
gotten all I've learned through all
death because they actually have a show
called roast meat and so though the
following of all death all the followers
and fans also they rose just naturally
because that's kind of the thing like so
they'll roast Doughboy that roasts me
and they'll give me heavy you know say
that's all I got used to it so when
people actually started trolling me on
my content on my page and it's not all
death they're actually like straight-up
roasting me like no hatin oh they
actually like I'll respond a rarely I'll
just do one little respond whatever just
a slight one and they'll be like all
Brighton dogs get you're gonna respond
I'm a fan like bro you [ __ ] always
happens I just want a reaction bro they
play all bro you should hella funny bro
like that I'm
come on fam sometimes I think they
they're just trying to be they really
think they're funny yeah just not mad
funny at all yeah they're just being
stupid yeah I always tell people like
just telling someone [ __ ] you is not
funny yeah that's not funny that's yeah
yeah yeah the people even adults alot yo
so I had this situation recently where
you know I just heard through a couple
of people I tweeted this [ __ ] recently
so this dude I heard from a couple of
friends who texted me they're like yo
did you and this guy I'm gonna say his
name like have some problems or some
[ __ ] like what do you mean he was like
he said well he's been telling me that
when he saw you like you were acting
like a [ __ ] and he says some [ __ ] to
your face and he said that you didn't
say anything and he's just like [ __ ]
sizing you up and whatever I'm like that
didn't happen nothing what are you
talking about yeah and I got like two or
three texts from different people and
I'm like so this guy was spreading [ __ ]
saying that he talked big he's like he's
like you talk about war stories yeah and
I'm like wait wow that's like I did see
him recently and I remember like I was
just kind of like joking with him and
he's kind of a freak
he's like an acquaintance right yeah but
you know like sometimes we just [ __ ]
rag on each other right and so I said
some [ __ ] to him and then we were all
laughing it off but he walked away I
guess he mumbled some [ __ ] and walked
away I guess whatever he mumbled he
turned that into me saying some [ __ ] to
him and then I just shut up I didn't say
anything back to him yeah oh my wait why
are you going around telling people this
story end of it I thought it was like
what he took his mumble and to himself
he was like yeah totally try yeah
irritated only because the story wasn't
true right and so I assumed that they
were all kicking it without me or
whatever cuz it's like back in
Sacramento yeah they're all kicking it
without me or some [ __ ] and he just told
us why he was drunk or something right
but he was like telling people
individually the same story over and
over and over I'm like what what's the
point of this yeah what are you doing
right so I literally texted him I was
like so you were talking [ __ ] [ __ ] to me
I say anything right question mark yeah
and he was like no no that's not what I
said man like well it's like a little
[ __ ] and I was like oh well cuz I'm
going back to Sacramento in like a month
it's like well I'll see you when I come
back and we'll have a conversation about
that right yeah that is a threatening
him us I just want to know why you
was probably sweating bricks there's
like marking off every day from the day
that David comes back you know he's all
like sweating should I know what his
problem is with me yes like I saw you
once we're pretty cordial like number
one if you thought that I was going to
in on you you could just be a mensch oh
I'm gonna [ __ ] my bed right because
that's how we grew up we you just always
rag on each other you were being
sensitive about that [ __ ] then you
should have let me know cuz you were he
was like clowning on me too so right it
was whatever right I just might have
one-up them a little harder you know but
whatever he did he mumbles some [ __ ] and
he kind of just was peacocking to people
I'm like why do this like even adults do
this she this mother [ __ ] three five
years old
yeah you hurt his feelings David that's
why it's so weird when I see a 35 year
old doing that [ __ ] I'm like Doug you're
a [ __ ] grown-ass man yeah and what
are you doing I would run away from that
kind of friend
that's why do I have that many friends
oh he's not gonna quaint his friend you
know I mean like one of those type of
things but yeah he's like I've known him
long enough where if I if he if he's in
town I'll say what's up yeah you know
what I mean but that was so [ __ ]
honest there's some people that like
they they don't really and just how they
were raised or what they've done like
just growing up whatever but it's like
they don't understand the social cues of
like this is probably gonna come back
around to me yeah you know I'm saying
like some people like to tell stories no
embellish it though they'll like add
extra [ __ ] yeah basically he pulled out
a knife and I was like oh really bro
yeah pull a knife out to a gunfight so I
pulled out my gun yeah and then you
started talking all this [ __ ] to where
they're like it was a [ __ ] grocery
bag what are you talking about yeah bro
the word sack of [ __ ] yeah yeah so like
my thing is like especially like being
in the Condor world is such a small last
world like in the comedy like doing
stand-up yeah like I'm more than likely
gonna see this comedian again for sure
oh there's no point in saying his set
was trash there's no point in saying
he's not funny or to like talking [ __ ]
about comedian it's gonna come back for
sure
you know I'm saying so my thing is like
oh and I do this for eight for anybody
like the safest thing to do is to speak
to somebody if they're not in the room
as if they were in the room yeah yes
that's the best way you could do it you
might think even if you are gonna talk
to it you can touch it all day you can't
get back to me [ __ ] you I'll [ __ ]
tell you
so like your [ __ ] [ __ ] I always say
this is if i'ma talk [ __ ] to your face
yeah I'm saying the same [ __ ] behind
your back so just know then I'm I keep
the same energy here and also there
right so if I said that [ __ ] behind your
face that you came up to me and you're
like I don't you're talking [ __ ] I was
like yup yeah I was talking mad [ __ ]
about right cuz I hate you like if they
heard that I talk [ __ ] there go on
really and then they get their feelings
hurt I think that's what really I know
one talk no one steps up to me no it was
like hey I heard you were talking [ __ ]
for someone within two seconds away from
levitating yeah so like was about to say
but [ __ ] okay I [ __ ] forgot dude I
forgot my mind went blank real quick
let's pick my nose I forgot you got
punched too much today yeah it's
definitely funny man like a lot of
people I guess um are kind of two-faced
like in the real world yeah I just don't
understand cuz I'm not surrounded by
that but I do remember like before I had
my solid group of friends that I do
right now yeah it was constantly like
weird [ __ ] going on yeah but like
thankfully I was in the world we're like
if you had [ __ ] you just kind of fight
and then you saw [ __ ] out yeah it's not
like to face and then I started hanging
out with some rich kids and that world
is totally so fake man yeah I mean not
all rich people are this way but it's
just my my experience of like how kids
do it
well not kids we're like in high school
in early college and stuff but the way
that they do it is is more mental and
emotional in a way like they they pull
strings but it's like a drama yeah I'm
like man this is crazy like I don't want
to be around this and they all just kind
of get it too like it's all just the
undertone of like we're talking [ __ ] but
we know that this is this is the [ __ ]
between us and if we want to mix it with
this and it's just that it's a it's a
[ __ ] game that they play and it's
just like I'm also somebody where - in
the sense of like
if somebody talks [ __ ] about something
that I do right I'm okay with it
as long as they know who they are right
so what I mean by that is let's say I do
a film right yeah and then somebody who
makes terrible films go hey man I don't
think your acting was great in this I'm
like you don't say [ __ ] well that's
offensive
you [ __ ] garbage piece of [ __ ] but if
they made Mad films it's like you say
whatever you want I'll take those notes
and I'll become better you know like so
I did this thing recently where you know
there was a show where I'd you know take
shots and we're drinking and they they
kind of chopped it up a little bit in a
way I didn't like because it made me
sound like I was talking [ __ ] about
Brendan Schaub okay I'm not so they
asked me like who's a comedian that you
just don't think they're stand-up is
that funny yeah I was being honest I was
like well like I they kind of took out
the part where I said I like Brendan
Schaub a lot and I'm rooting for him but
I saw his last special I didn't like it
right right I just felt that it was too
early for him to have an hour special
because he only started doing stand-up
like two three years ago yeah sure so
you know I just felt like it wasn't that
great yeah Joe Rogan backs him up a lot
so I feel like it just seems like he's
catering and that things was special for
me it didn't make me crack up that's why
I liked it much yeah but it sounded like
I was saying he was hot trash I cut all
of that say was that he has the ability
to be really good because I'm sure he
works his [ __ ] you better clear it up
cuz he could [ __ ] you up - he's [ __ ]
tall when I went to go see Theo I was
like damn you're tall [ __ ]
yeah so that wasn't even the case I say
oh man I feel like that was gonna come
and bite me in the ass later but you
know I just tell him was like if he
asked me well you know am i special but
you know for sure cuz I'm a nobody
compared to him I would be like well I
didn't like it but I'm allowed not to
like it because I wasn't watching as a
comic I'm watching as somebody who likes
to watch stand-up right right I'm saying
as an audience member yeah I just didn't
think it was that funny right and I'll
be it he might come up to me he goes you
know what nothing you do is funny I'm
like you're a title tonight okay yeah I
don't think that's really talking [ __ ]
cuz you're not talking about what he
should have done that's what that's
where it would have been talking [ __ ]
yeah you're like it's not funny but if
you would have done this yeah I just
said you didn't like it whatever I just
thought it was Naamah so it was too
early for him to have an hour special
they just didn't feel as developed I
thought he could have it just felt like
they were I was waiting for the
punchline right yeah and I thought to me
I said was that I think Joe Rogan is
like a big catalyst for him yeah it
works really hard yeah but maybe he just
needed to work a little bit that's
tricky though because if you have a wave
and your wave is gonna catch that horn
yeah you have to stay on it cuz if you
because for him I guess he might have
been on a wave and you know yeah for
sure and build and build bit tours like
he got this special deal to the where
it's like [ __ ] I could I could play the
smart game and be patient and be like oh
let me go this way let me yeah let me do
more comic clothes at it up but if you
wanted to get it that that money in that
check yes I gotta make you know on it
and I think mentally - I'm a little
[ __ ] up but then that's where you need
a team yeah I feel like I'm a little
[ __ ] up too because he's he's also I'm
also comparing him to Joe Rogan and feel
want those are the people that he rolls
with right yeah maybe I expect going off
of their credits being saying like well
Joe Rogan and via and Theo yeah they're
they're backing you so it's like you
must be up at their little you put the
expectation on them yeah so maybe that's
what it is - yeah cuz obviously I mean
he's selling out shows so people find
the [ __ ] funny right
so Who am I to say [ __ ] you know I mean
yeah that's another thing too because
there's so many specials on Netflix
you watch them you'll be like watch
standability what the thing is is that
they have their own following yeah yeah
they have that theater is sold out for a
reason somebody I'm saying they all
found him funny and that's what I
learned from Kevin stage is that um this
is like I'm trying to like copy his
blueprint which he know he tells all the
homies I broke just post content it does
not matter if you think it's trashed you
think it's funny somebody finds a funny
somebody will find it funny he said that
there's somebody out in the world that
likes black licorice true and so and I
don't know how they're Swedish that's
I'll let you know right now they're
Swedish Swedish people like what that
being said post it bro post it I mean
cuz we're all worst critics you know I'm
saying like all gonna be trashed it's
gonna be you know mean just make content
man I post it all but I don't even make
it you know what is that - just like
such a tricky thing to come it's like I
think that the hardest thing is most P
when they try to do stand-up because
I've been doing sin since I was 16 right
so just as young as I could I tried it
out
yeah obviously I took a fat break to do
film but there's this thing of we kind
of hold things a little too precious
right so we're just like oh that might
be funny not but you but you have to go
up on stage and work it to make it funny
yeah cuz that's the hard part right you
have to be willing to bomb this joke to
figure out what's wrong with it yeah
rework it yeah and a lot of people had
that weird fear that like Oh what if I
Bob well good then take that joke and
say was it funny right you know cuz what
if you thought your set was [ __ ]
perfect you didn't try it out yeah you
went up there and you [ __ ] oh hell
yeah bro I've had my worst bomb was in
Houston where that's my hometown from so
my worst mob was actually um on I got to
go on on a weekend with a fee on Crocky
oh yeah yeah yeah so a fee on he saw me
in North Hollywood at the haha comedy
club and he saw me do my thing I had a
great show and this is like my first
year in comedy and so oh [ __ ] that was
[ __ ] brand-new yeah brand-new but I
just had a solid set yeah I'm saying to
wear a feel almost like bro you're funny
you know me and then also with being in
theater stuff I had a confidence being
on stage and in front of people so even
if something wasn't as funny I could
still play with it and play along to
where people liked you know they were
entertained yeah so anyway if you're on
oh I like I saw he was going to Houston
so I hit him up on Twitter like a man
I'm from Houston you know I can bring
people out you know whatever and so he
he got me he got me the weekend and
stuff so he he gave me an opening spot
and I think it was a I think it was the
Friday night I do five minutes and it
was okay right was I yeah and so of the
second show it was two shows Friday the
second show you he'll just like you know
a man are you good man I know you're
funny you know it's all it happens it it
uh he gave he gave me his bomb story and
you know make me feel better and then so
the second show on Friday I did I do it
again and again it's still I it's it's
not what he saw at in North Hollywood
was it the same set that's it same say
it just it just still wasn't going with
the same yeah yeah and in the audience
it
was more of an older audience as well
that's the hard part
yeah and I'm only 19 so it's just like
how can this guy how can we connect what
experience that you're talking to me
about right right and I'm saying nothing
that has I'm talking about like you're
turning up in the definition to turn up
and and it's an older crowd like they
don't you know me so he was a heel just
like eight
I'll tell you what come back um I might
have gotten this oh this actually
happened on the Thursday night show
because he told me to skip Friday
he said come back on a Saturday was the
bigger show so I think I think that's
what happened you and I was just like no
no I got it let me because he gave me
the whole week and I was like nah just
let me let me come back Friday let me do
it Friday Tubber thing he was like all
right but I telling you bro I think it'd
be better if you do Saturday yeah it's
gonna be a bigger crowd you'll have a
lot more of you know freedom to have fun
as though that I was like nah I got you
Friday
I'm coming up coming stronger I'm saying
so I go I go and when I on the way back
on the web driving to the comment Club
I'm thinking of a joke that I'm like oh
this is what I'm gonna open with and
it's a whole new joke that I've never
even tried bro there's no never tried it
but I just had this confidence of like
man [ __ ] that say you know be a book
that's a yesterday I'll do some fresh
imma give him something fresh i'ma have
fun with it this is my city
i'ma represent like all this [ __ ] first
joke go onstage bro first joke I'm
talking about tanked crickets crickets
bro you can hear the cooks in the back
you know civil we're being watched it
was like a Chinese guy they're back oh
my gosh she was your guy it was bad to
wear like a Theon and in the feature
we're watching from the side right by
the by the green room and you can hear
them go stay on there for four long
minutes for more long minutes and so I
get offstage bed and you know he didn't
give me the whole pep talk about it's
all good like he just kind of stay like
chill it you know to check night news I
told you yeah I mean my own little like
gonna kill myself and I got bumped that
cuz yeah so it was a Friday because I
got bumped off to the rest of the
weekend like they know the communion on
the car
I remember um I remember after the
Friday night we're all leaving as
someone I was just like I told everyone
I was like hey but that Saturday go that
Saturday like you said that says gonna
be bigger than he'll just like a man you
know you did your thing bro you know I'm
proud of you in it and I know that
you're I know it you're funny bro but
what you need to do is go back to LA and
and really work on your [ __ ] you know
this is Ned and he'll just like it's
just as the business move man it's kind
of hard for comedians to pick back up
that energy when you know and he's like
I can't risk that you know I mean so at
least he was honest with you yeah yeah
yeah he did his thing he was honest with
me and then um said that following here
he went back to Houston and brought me
back yeah gave me a chance and I was
there all also if you did a good oh yeah
cuz that's the hard part - I think like
when I found out especially do like
these college shows that you got to look
at the crowd like your set your set has
to make micro adjustments depending on
who the crowd is smallest ones yeah yeah
it's like okay well if I went out and
then I'm used to doing like these like
jokes about drinking and partying or
whatever and I look at the crowd that 56
years old aside well how can I make this
funny - then yeah yeah relationships or
it could be the smallest things of like
um you know what was partying like back
there yeah you know me talk to a crowd
like a couple who's hella old and yeah
you know asking them what well how did
John me in the club how are y'all
getting down because this is how we get
down you go you go you're set you got to
make it relatable and set it up right
right so like even I know like when I go
to these college shows like I can't talk
about to crazy [ __ ] because I feel like
when sometimes like a younger crowds a
little sensitive so they just haven't
been scarred by the world enough yet so
when you say greatest [ __ ] they're like
I can't believe you said that it hurts
their feelings I gotta tune it down yeah
you leave that [ __ ] for the company when
you first started doing college so is
like out an 0:09 people were crazier
yeah yeah we would be it we would say
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] why yeah yeah
that's ten years I've never done
colleges bro I've always wanted to I
think there's also like a there's also
NACA yeah like but I've never you know
been a part of that I would love to use
fun though man it's it's real fun it's
different when they know you already
because you don't have to
I could have a set where people get to
know you or you got to build that
rapport just go straight into it yeah I
heard that that's kind of how a lot of
comic comics work now cuz they have the
podcasts so their audience is already
coming yeah so then at that point they
have inside jokes and whatever and they
just play off of that show that's why
like I watched a lot of these comics and
I see the crowd cracking up I don't know
what's going on it's because I'm not a
fan of theirs right but they already
know and that's the cool thing about
stand-up - like once you start getting a
name yourself you're not really catering
to a new crowd you're just kind of
catering to whatever yeah right
so like I mean not everybody's gonna be
a [ __ ] Dave Chappelle right you know
right and I think that was the the
hardest thing for for me when I was
younger I just I kept on idolized
idolizing these comics and I'm like if I
might if my sets not anywhere as good as
theirs I'm just not gonna do it which
sucks because it's just you know who
you're comparing yourself to it you know
yeah those are like those those [ __ ]
dime a dozen human beings yeah you know
like the Michael Jackson of freaking
comedy right yeah I mean just watching
his new [ __ ] his last special on
Netflix I was like yo how the [ __ ] did
he get better like I don't get this [ __ ]
like I don't understand how he got
better he took a long hiatus and got
buff and for him yeah you got buff on
the in and another thing whenever he was
just like oh I'm I pulled this random
joke out of a out of a bag he was just
like he said the joke and then still he
told you how the joke is gonna go set it
and hit the punchline and still hit like
it still was funny and it's the same
like even like the way he carries his
cockiness it's not even so cocky worst
distasteful it just makes you laugh oh
that's dope that's the dopest a man Oh
Eddie Murphy has that time where Eddie
Murphy has that swag um Jamie Foxx has
that swag Jim Carrey does it well he Jim
Carrey does a he's I mean he thought
he's obviously more comedic acting heavy
now because like one or two but he was
really good at with act outs and yes he
would play that cocky yeah game you know
me on the interview shows and like late
night shows stuff like that and it
always worked bro that's what Ellen did
on her last one the relatable special
really killed it her first like 10 15
minutes was awesome like cocky [ __ ] but
it was just funny bro yeah
she was it was a solid as of special for
sure yeah I mean I'd stand up such a
very interesting game because I feel
like when I when I started acting like
people were asking me you know so how
did you feel about these auditions mind
you the first audition that I had I was
[ __ ] nerve wrecking and everything
but after a while like but the thing
that helped me kind of reel it in was
nothing will be more nerve-wracking than
standing line I don't I don't think
going into an audition with three people
is ever gonna be as nervous as me
walking as a nobody comic trying to get
in on the list yeah just to do a five
minute [ __ ] set it right up like
sixty drunk people well I mean I would
say that I think it's uh I think maybe
because on stage I don't really care if
all of them don't accept me if I'm cool
with just a small group like accepting
and we're getting laugh stand out I'll
grab tip my energy towards the end more
or I can end up winning a crowd yeah in
an audition I only have one shot to make
these three people accept me hmm and
make sure I booked it so that's the I
guess I guess maybe not nerve-wracking
but the stakes are higher in an audition
auditions to meet I maybe were what
y'all think you know what it is it's
like but you got to realize to work when
you go to go to these auditions at the
end of the day they know what they want
if you know yeah you just don't how I
learned that at all that day I hate
waiting
I that's the worst thing for me not not
actually auditioning but you're sitting
there for like hours and hours because
it's that drives me crazy it's not even
the fact that you're a lot of the times
is that these people are bad actors yeah
a lot of us are bad at auditioning my
auditioning is a skill right because
you're trying to impress them in this
small window in an audition 101 class
okay $800 for one deal to be like when
you walk in
don't shake their hand it's a mind trick
and they do this whole thing you know
but uh it's like you also have like I
learned it all deaf actually when they
were doing their um they were doing
auditions for whatever hosting gig or
whatever piece of content they were
doing they had auditions and I was on
the other end and that's where I learned
Oh like whenever they're like oh this
person was really good but it's just not
the look we're going for what you want
already you already know what you want
so it's like it's not anything on there
not on you at all so that
that helped with auditioning because
it's just like i'ma go in there if y'all
want me a I'll just get to these lines
real quick and I'm out yeah I'm saying
cuz they already know what you want you
know yeah you feel that energy when they
know when they see that you know for
sure dude they'll get out their chairs
they're go to you to shave yeah oh hey
Heidi those were you waiting too long it
though though they'll treat you
differently yeah 100% so there was a
casting director that's from Houston and
he was like he was like oh you from you
said Oh what part it that was like
wasting like 10-15 minutes of talking
about you Stan because there boy -
they're seeing the same [ __ ] yeah and it
was just on and you know I feel bad
because I feel like i overstepped a
whole bunch of people but you know what
built that connect yeah be memorable
like some of the best advice that I got
especially for auditioning was like you
know just be unapologetically yourself
read the lines that you could read if
you get a redirect had the skills enough
to understand that redirect and smash it
out the park right you can't not be
yourself and that's the hardest part is
for people to do these lines in their
own voice and your own interpretation to
the best that you can
right and that's the hard part right so
I think like because I got that advice
early on like I just said [ __ ] it
whatever right and so I remember when I
was having these these meetings with a
casting directors yeah I don't know what
the [ __ ] with a general meeting was I
just walked in right I just walked in
and I walked in flip-flops and socks and
basketball shorts and tank top gave it
and there was like the [ __ ] but the cool
thing was but when I had a conversation
with the master will you get drinks or
whatever I'm like well yy-you yeah you
know just be real like you know why
you're hitting me up to get grab drinks
or whatever because I remembered you
last night might remember me she goes
well I've never had somebody come into a
general meeting and treat me like they
didn't care I just didn't know what was
going on yeah it was like well usually
when people have general meetings they
do their hair up they get a haircut they
really they present themselves you
impress them by being [ __ ] nasty and
that's so crazy too cuz industry loves
to be reminded of regular world things
and I'm saying instead of staying
because it gets exhausting like you said
it's all day there yeah uh-huh yeah we
were pitching a show we would go to all
these [ __ ] group like pitches right
here and then the the do that that
brought us out
he's a dope as producer and I mean he
made the show [ __ ] smarter than a
fifth grader and she liked that right
yeah so then we were we were pitching a
reality show like kind of like Jay King
news but like a twist with it and we
would go into like MTV and whatever in
all these places and then he was like be
completely yourself yes exactly as you
would but clean up a little bit you know
you don't have to wear like a mustard
stained shirt but just be there and
we're like cool so I'll go in short
sandals and [ __ ] like a Hawaiian
shirt or whatever yeah like we go in and
we kill it and every single time
everyone's like I love this like
authenticity it's dope every day this is
what Hollywood's missing right right and
we get callbacks and [ __ ] but it's like
a lot of moving pieces to it manage so
our yeah the hard part is I think the
turnaround like what I realized is that
MTV might might want you right right but
like the the sitting director might
change in three months yeah and they
moved to another company yeah and in the
marketing was like so the person that I
auditioned for before might might have
left it months ago right so it's like
the same company but the people are
constantly changing yeah so you got to
keep auditioning to the same company and
you're like what the [ __ ] dude yeah I
thought I was in good yeah and then they
keep changing like what do you call it
like goals yeah they're like all we're
looking for an Asian group or we're
looking for this we were trying to do
this kind of comedy and in two months
later they're like nah now we're gonna
work on films yeah like stick to your
[ __ ] man yeah yeah they probably have
good reason for doing it but well yeah
that's what I'm saying it's best I
learned so much man in the past like a
couple years working for at a network
you know those are the things that that
that our conversations that are being
had like when something is pitched and
they like the idea or like and then
switching it to a different angle and
it's all and then people are left on
like waiting lists or whatever you know
seeing a whole vision board and
everything and then it's like oh nah
we'll go this with you know I've seen
all these things happening and being in
these rooms from like it makes total
sense to where it takes off all the
stress on me because the only thing I
can do is like you said be yourself and
be the [ __ ] like like after your lines
nail your [ __ ] nail exactly which you
know put the work in be yourself and
that's all you can do that's why I
didn't I started hitting like this
his rhetoric that was going on Twitter
you know specifically in our community
like Asian community right there like I
understand that we have very poor
representation in our films right I
think the part that annoyed me just to
grab back to the thought of no your
place is you can't talk about well I got
into the audition the reason why I
didn't get it is cuz I was Asian
no because you suck bro yeah I know you
personally mean you [ __ ] suck someone
was good and like a good actor and he
didn't get it right I'll be like oh that
sucks what's wrong with them they didn't
choose you right a lot of the cases
ma'am the people that cry the most are
the sorriest and they didn't do their
time to practice they they make make up
[ __ ] like Oh cuz I'm Asian I didn't get
hired and that's the thing cuz that's uh
because Gary Vee said that he was like
if somebody successful looks like you
then there's no excuses
yeah yeah if they look just like and
they have no millionaire whatever
successful within your industry and he
looked just like you that same culture
everything then there's no excuses to be
bitching about all it's because of this
or it's because of this hundred percent
man I mean there's the obvious racism
that still is out there yeah but there's
still people who have broke those
boundaries for us to follow yeah I mean
I mean I always tell people like look
man if Bruce Lee was alive today he
would be still famous yeah I mean he's
still he's a legend right the only
reason why is because he pioneered and
changed so much right don't just be good
right he be a [ __ ] be someone that
changes [ __ ] yeah and so like when a lot
of wear a poncho wear sombreros go out
to Boyle Heights yeah [ __ ] draw that
grease mustache on your face it's not
enough to be just a good actor yeah like
you you got to be good with networking
you got to be good with all kinds of
[ __ ] it's got to have a different way of
thinking there are changes [ __ ] right
like and I think people don't understand
that like to be number one or to be
somebody that's extraordinary
mmm-hmm you really gotta invent some
[ __ ] and be different and work like
crazy you gotta do extraordinary [ __ ]
right for sure yeah I don't know anyone
that's successful that was handed like
an even
if they do for a short stint they can't
keep that favor they can't keep that
successor right and so that's what
people don't understand is like man your
idea of hard work sometimes is not
really hard work right yeah it's just
actually just working yeah regular work
yeah I've seen people put and work like
they sleep two hours a day like I mean
they put in work yeah and it's like oh
yeah you deserve it man you deserve all
the riches like you [ __ ] don't have
any wife and you're sad as [ __ ] and you
work all day it's like yeah but you're a
millionaire yeah you deserve those
millions cuz you sacrifice so much for
right yeah a lot of [ __ ] that goes with
it man yeah but people they think like
peanuts right so they don't really
understand what it takes to be the top
and I'm like I don't want to be the top
because I've seen what it took to be the
top dog and it's like oh man that kind
of sucks I just want to find a lotto
ticket dude I just want to start doing
fun [ __ ] just for [ __ ] fun cuz right
now I feel like we get word in that
space so we're still working for a
paycheck right mm-hmm so imagine like
being like Adam Sandler was just it's
kind of good the one on Netflix did you
see that woman history 101 the let the
latest Adam Sandler movie I saw was a
mr. Wexler Drexler was it he was that
he's a UH he's the producer oh it's like
a true story about do the layers yeah
like that that one actually got me bro
like man that would be fun if we just
like make our own see I don't like
auditioning but I love telling stories
and I like writing and creating
characters right so it just takes a lot
of [ __ ] money to make it happen yeah
yeah man I can't wait we just we will
get rich one day and start [ __ ]
around and that and that's the thing too
like that's what's so dope about these
um like these patrons and my GoFundMe or
stuff like that to where you have people
who actually believe your content your
personality your to your brand to where
they'll help yeah you know I'm saying
because it's obviously we can't get in
these rooms to ask for these loans and
ask for these you know cuz that's all
we're asking for we're not asking for
money to go do dumb [ __ ]
David who's that lottery to you because
I'm asked for some dumb [ __ ] right but
it's like we're just trying to create
some [ __ ] yeah you know me if we had
this money a budget to make the the
sketches or do these dim the short films
that you know with all these different
characters we'd be doing it right now
but we don't have the money
that's the only thing for sure yeah well
that's the end of this podcast yep
that's pretty [ __ ] good that was
pretty good I went through like nothing
yeah on the show quiz reciate it when
they find you at y'all can follow me on
all platforms Christy no Sousa no H just
CR is TI n Oh keep me on my Instagram
and follow your boy is poppin over there
alright and then you guys will catch us
on iTunes Spotify cashbox whatever you
can find an audio platform where there
if there aren't iTunes make sure you
give us that five star cuz we [ __ ]
need it I'm sucking dick for a living so
let you guys know my lips are chapped
and my [ __ ] throats tired so next
week we want to make a film